♪ A long, long time ago, ♪
♪ I can still remember ♪
♪ when the jump-cut was all the rage ♪
♪ And I knew if I could get it right, ♪
♪ that those friendly editors just might ♪
♪ maybe ♪
♪ feature me up on the front page... ♪
♪ But now that might be in the past. ♪
♪ To please the teeming corporate mass, ♪
♪ oh, that dream might now be dead, ♪
♪ despite the ads by my head. ♪
♪ And as hard as YouTube tries to ♪
♪ offer excuses and official whys, ♪
♪ we'll find the truth within the lies ♪
♪ the day ♪
♪ the YouTubes died. ♪
♪ Oh why, why am I even surprised? ♪
♪ Maybe YouTube can be Hulu and avoid its demise, ♪
♪ but if it comes at the cost of the little guys, ♪
♪ then I think that I might say my goodbyes... ♪
♪ I think that I might say my goodbyes. ♪
♪ Did you do the Five Facts thing ♪
♪ or participate in the Google Verb Meme? ♪
♪ Well I sure had fun with those. ♪
♪ And do you remember your First comment, ♪
♪ and how much those few characters meant? ♪
♪ Well, now you're a pro at the Captcha codes. ♪
♪ Well I know that I will miss it all ♪
♪ when I'm stuck behind this content wall. ♪
♪ Maybe it won't spell curtains. ♪
♪ I'll still have my subscriptions. ♪
♪ Yeah, I want Kevjumba, Smosh, and Buck! ♪
♪ Forget all your high-budget junk! ♪
♪ Well I hope they won't be out of luck ♪
♪ the day ♪
♪ the YouTubes died. ♪
♪ I started vloggin' ♪
♪ Why, why am I even surprised? ♪
♪ Maybe YouTube can be Hulu and avoid its demise, ♪
♪ but if it comes at the cost of the little guys, ♪
♪ then I think that I might say my goodbyes. ♪
♪ I think that I might say my goodbyes... ♪
Everybody with me one time!
♪ Why, why am I even surprised? ♪
♪ Maybe YouTube can be Hulu and avoid its demise, ♪
♪ but if it comes at the cost of the little guys, ♪
♪ then I think I might say my goodbyes. ♪
♪ I think I might say my goodbyes. ♪
That was hilariously difficult.
First, I had to tape this to my camera
so that I could remember all the chords
So that's why I didn't realize there was a big reflection in my eyeball the whole time,
because I couldn't see myself on my monitor.
And second, I kept doing this:
♪ Why, why am I even surprised? ♪
♪ Maybe Vader someday later,
now he's just a small-fry. ♪
♪ And those good 'ol boys
were drinking whiskey and rye- ♪
Yes, there can be too many parodies for one song.
Sorry to contribute to that.
Wardrobe change!
Thank-yous go to all the people in that little YouTube chorus.
Alan, fallofautumndistro, of course,
for writing most of that song.
But most of all, thanks to all of you,
because YouTube is not what Google does.
YouTube is what we do,
and what you're doing down there.
I'm sure you know what I mean...by down there.
So thank you for doing what we do,
because it's freakin' awesome.
And I got a haircut! What do you think?